all right Nick we are live welcome to
the I lords pocket and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 112 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the roundtable on the Lord's and
today Darrell will rejoice we got part
two of the 2019 prediction series and
Sony is next up to bat
I'm extremely proud to have all this
PlayStation royalty here at the round
table so we gonna get right into it I
want to introduce the Lord whose love of
PlayStation brand and last of us
franchise is truly evident and
everything he does this Lord is easily
one of the most entertaining followers
on Twitter fellow brother and iron and -
the hoopin and Hollerin will give you
the real or PlayStation reviews
introducing the creating host of the
silver sky YouTube channel one of the
funniest gaming families on Twitter
Habakkuk for limb separation and the
Lord who shames grown men for being too
high for Nintendo products live from
Dallas and making his debut into the
realm of the Lord
mommy Lois silver Scott five four five
how you doing sir oh my god that was
amazing
oh oh you believe in intros that was no
I'll just say one thing in 2019 how are
you still repping the Xbox welcome to
the fold excited to be here got pulled
over on the way track Adele was rushing
hello go buy some violet ladies some
donuts and thankfully my complexion a
lot of mediocrity shot to make it a Opie
good to have you brother thank you and
of course we have the Lord with just the
mere mention of his name is synonymous
with the greatness that is a PlayStation
introducing the host of the jw2 Jack
and the creator of the iconic
PlayStation contract the Lord most
responsible for making your favorite
youtuber jump ship and the tradition at
the king of the Twitter gifts and your
memes if you know what I mean live from
that stuff in the screw Houston and
making his return into the realm of the
lords my main lord jwa a Kratos are you
doing sir
yo yo yo what's up here buddy doing good
there's a Playstation contract remedy
and we all like signing my life away
[Laughter]
exactly man willing and Dillon hey Yoshi
- Toby man you know we got bounties out
here on how we know you ain't part of
Google's little camp now
you never know sir you know every other
day I changed my logo so pregnant chick
this is so true like when I say y'all
ready no I don't take else I will run
from an ill so put on the statue for the
careless it's like literally his name -
like what you play a man I'm uh I'm
wrapping up the days gone that
everybody's golf VR I've been
at some don't lose on the PC mmm World
War Z you know something I'm yeah back
and forth I'm switching stuff with
Mortal Kombat everywhere man you back
brother appreciated and of course last
but certainly not least we have a Lord
whose clear and concise contents now mix
revoir and uncut honesty easily make him
one of my top 5 dead or alive content
creators in the game
introducing the host of the iconic
weapon will podcast the Lord of
PlayStation difficulty trophies not
playing old games and you know as Last
of Us multiplayer as one of the best
generator where's Brooklyn at making his
return it's in the realm of the lowest
not me
Lord broken games HD are how you do
exist you know what's up man glad to be
here uh I'm just curious you said you
said dead or alive what dead cottons
around here dead we gotta flip it on
glad to be here weapon we'll podcast
weapon you already know it hey you
already know we got the Four Horsemen of
gaming those original Lords here at the
round table
my calls would call most my brother from
another mother the difficult game
khakhra and the half of the young wolf
mommy
Lord addict how you doin sir doing
pretty good sitting currently sitting in
a 30,000 uh oh
thirty thousand line for four dollars I
don't know like I don't know that this
game must be like made out of gold or
something from thirty thousand people to
sit online to play it
oh you playing the game right now well
we own a podcast
man I play always playing Final Fantasy
seven but I haven't been able to play my
switch a whole lot at work here lately
but um I'm probably gonna jump back on
it cuz we are coming up on e3 and I'm
gonna have a lot of time like on the
plane it's the it's like a six hour
flight between gear in LA so that's a
I'll definitely try to finish that you
actually go in the e3 just cuz Sony's
not going to everyone needs that guy LP
is gonna be out this we don't understand
I don't know uh listen I told everybody
in my podcast I'm listen I'm not going
anybody want to go like that it's two
free season they were like nah bro we
good Oh
BG why you don't want to go see that uh
inside Xbox III man I heard they might
show out we don't know hey this time
they bring in the Mangala strangler and
of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo game Elizabeth play
a selfish experience and also the sastra
darkness mr. orth lab profile Illuminati
and lower patreon of the iron bake nah
man Lord sovereign are you doing sir
the other man was going on this is crazy
man you know gotta relax a little bit
this week more than using you yeah
actually uh you could turn the fried the
frog light off King I played some games
this week all right
but it wasn't we're supposed to be
playing like the one game you don't got
me invested in that I have not finished
I will be so sorry miss King I have to
play with somebody else is overrated
yeah so I picked up the UH I picked up
that rez equal 4 and s which man I
haven't played this is the GameCubes
well I had a lot of points so it came to
like 5 books just for buying $30 for one
game look at you talking about it also
played I got to play that on the Neo
alpha neo to alpha on a Playstation and
I mean it's good it's it's in one year
which is not a bad thing I mean II you
know is definitely a different beast to
like a regular Souls game or suck your
old but that neo is crazy man just the
customization options all the damn and
weapons like all the different like the
magic and stuff it's just a different
beast and and suck your own or anything
else out of out of from so I'm excited
to see what it is cuz it seems like it's
just more of the same now they gave you
a character customizer now which made
sense it
since then the first one you really like
using all kinds of different helmets and
armor and stuff like that so you barely
see your characters face anyway
so on it had double axes that they added
to the game which is very cool
beyond that general like you gotta like
kind of similar to as far as features
yeah who gonna kick out yeah the first
one it was it was William number I gave
me Jamie cracker I was like yeah the
samurai William so I mean yeah I mean I
think it's great I'm not quite sure when
the game is launching but it was a
decent amount decent chunk of gameplay
they gave me out and that was it that's
what's up and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk Curtis aka the XS gamer
ooh the lord of combat sports king of
the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
fantastic
welcome to the Voltron edition we're all
Lions must be in line as you can tell
for dominance fences I would like all
the knees in the basket to your left I
would like you to cut them off shea
butter them up because I don't want no
ashy knees in the basket the Lord King
himself see this is my box for my knees
it has been shipped to me I need more
knees this is fantastic
yo bro who did this for you like who did
this for what a year does boy like you
like leading up to it like dude was
talking mad trash and then was like one
day it was like boom and it was like
silence like Neverland
I don't know what day the week it was I
do remember that happened that made this
it was a tweet that went out and it was
like the horrifying you know how you
open your phone you don't you don't want
to swipe left like it's like it's like
left before you're on the phone and saw
something that you didn't
and these dudes swipe left and saw a
picture that was like yeah we looked at
the hospital records dude was in the
hospital the ambulance goes to the doors
it was not good checking all people you
okay are you okay oh god oh god I can't
come back from this no I can't front in
one fell swoop you came in and took me
it was like it was having good like
moves oh ok so Sean seven eight six
eight King make sure you jump is my
brother y'all really don't know we
really talk behind the scenes laughing
it was like cuz it was having crazy
traction and you know things moving
forward but then BOOM
somebody put a brick in front of the
door we go get it to this other that
would you replace it oh man my destiny
to crack addiction has started all over
again
you know I've been playing The Reckoning
so hard on level three because this is
what the bougie comes back in if you
can't get to the level three I don't
want to talk to you you know anything
right yeah get off my timeline stop
playing with me I'm not going back doing
level tools you know buddy I got to do
level three that gear and I'm out here
chasing the level three gear and it
turns the game into something totally
different
again it's like the other month these
guys is reinventing itself and I watched
um the last word shout-out to um lordy
pontus oh ya ain't getting it in
um and I listened to you guys about the
um the Year opulence yeah oh my god I'm
so excited for that like you y'all guys
broke it down so my silly behind can
understand it and I was like yeah I
understand people is upset with all the
nerves and stuff that's going down yeah
Lynch minute a chat with the father
super chat let's get the green rolling
in cheers from Germany to the ILP the
panel and King David Lord of the needs
yeah that's it man I've been trying I've
seen you jump on or whatever but no deaf
singer hear you oh yeah building what's
going on baby salute Lord's question for
the panel how long is Saudis III gonna
be and how many flute man we did and J
sells more snake oil bit marks are all
of course we had a lot of the
cooperative experience in gaming in
himself
they shouldn't OB law Cognito spread
never listen aroma IOP not telling you
what you want to hear what you mean to
hear so for me yeah dauntless I'm trying
to do the same thing on all platform the
same thing attic man and I have the same
files try it on place because I'm going
to see the cross play aspect and
launched on three I've just been having
problems getting into now in the whole
situation so yes you know just that
little MK on a switch destiny and all
bit but anyway let's get into these
topics and the reason we are here the
state of Sony so we got the prediction
series we want to do a we don't brief
recap of 2019
you know Sony's been moving out here
close to 97 million PlayStation 4 sold
I'm releasing he's gone you know I'm
saying it's just been a very pretty much
successful run for them and then I'll
see some of the latest news we've got
the memorandum of understanding with
microscope you know as far as this as
your servers and then um obviously we
still got the Nintendo switch moving and
shaking out here and be and out she
taking it your parents old coming in you
know eateries approach we know so he's
not gonna be if you will get into that
aspect but I just want able to discuss
how
we feeling about Sony 2019 so I want to
give it off the BG first so video set it
off like how are we feeling about Sony
2019-20 as far as games go
what are you okay as days gone um so far
right that's it right that we get those
dreams is in beta right yeah well you
know everybody knows I've been ragging
on days going for wow you know how I do
I pick on Twitter you know I pick a
target and I go oh stay on I stay on
target for a while until I get a new
target to move on you know I did it
bothers a lot of people but you know I
just feel like somebody has to you know
keep people in check is all about checks
and balances you can't have people that
people just out here praising games that
don't deserve praise all willy-nilly so
oh no we got pressed I started reviewing
you see you gave it like it was pretty
solid I felt your review of Days going I
mean I did I did I knew I did an
impression compressions I'm sorry
correct yes so and
I'm playing it right now actually trying
to get through it but listen everybody's
telling me oh you got to get here you
got to get here why why I gotta get so
far in the game to like start enjoying
it I'm at least 25 hours in and to me
it's just you know very mediocre and
been pretty okay so all the Sony think
they got him everything that man just
said you can go ahead and just discredit
I don't know what's wrong with him that
person who keeps dropping in and out you
must be on Xbox Live oh my
then this is coming from a guy who said
Tomb Raider is better than The Last of
Us if you language shows guys the Lord
good bziu back sir
I don't think so you might be in the
bushes still so you'll keep it moving so
they come back to send my goons at him
real quick
give me your state of Sony 2019 how we
feeling that I was going on listen I
mean 2019 you got to realize we had a
spectacular year last year and coming
off of the game of the year coming off
for the game of the Year winner yeah and
a handful of contenders yeah that's
right a man that Spiderman was
outstanding
tell him Kratos spider-man game of the
year edition that war is back in the
bushes you see what you see what it is
spider-man colors came in I'll take a
right then you know what that's more
impressive because think about it like I
see it
Game of the Year winner and concerns and
we got more than once so yeah that's
that's a good thing right so 20 was a
spectacular year all about this year
kind of starting off a little slow you
know they tense critters oh here's the
thing when you stomping somebody's leg
you gotta let them breathe every now and
then
oh sorry look they're gonna they're
gonna slow it down a little bit take a
little breather give the guys their own
III and see what they can do and think
about it man if you give the competition
their own space write their own spray
their own event oh and if they still
lose then you got what you got you know
you know it's some Lodi to the battle
but this here is a games game right
games games this is not a you at the end
of the day we all know Microsoft can go
and buy every company out there it's
welcome oh that was always a a what do
you call it Microsoft really wanted to
know they'll just cut the chick and let
that be that yeah we see yeah with that
money back mm-hmm
and he ruffled he show people you know
they show people hey we are the kings of
gaming when it comes to this guy you
know how you feeling about the beta of
dreams
because they do they can show much
nonsense for two hours and then Sony
could go oh by the way here's the
release date for last was part 2 oh yeah
everybody forgot about Xbox now here's
the thing selves gotta hold on to that
door because I definitely want you
touching on something I want to get to
but I just want to focus on what you
felt about Sonia this year absolutely
day's going you're a big fan of that you
know like well this year I enjoyed this
I would say a big fan I want to buy
because that's my next Sony purchase
right um and I'm waiting for my
Microsoft dollars to come in for me to
actually purchase it so my question is
um how because everybody it's like so
polarized in this game and I thought it
was great from what I was seeing and um
it's just I'm getting too many either
positive and negatives and not like
really done online you call it down
online
please tell me exactly what's up with
this game so I like to pair film and TV
shows with my games it's not a play I
don't play a whole lot anymore cuz I got
really put some long story if you care
to know about you can watch the podcast
I did with wingy gaming oh yeah great
podcast yo I like to thank you so I have
some addiction issues you know like like
always BG keeps dropping out right
before but uh yeah so I got I was real
addicted to online games so I had to
quit all that kind of cold turkey so the
reason why I say all that is because
with I now only play single-player here
and there
Diana with days gone I went back and I
watch them I watched uh the new show
that just came out black Sunday I think
in a year so I watched that entire
series I watched I am Legend again which
I think days gone is more has more in
common with I am Legend okay
it's as far as it'll make sense when you
play the full game but anyway so I tried
to get myself hyped up through shows and
whatnot
so I enjoyed the game because I was
already invested in that world but I
have a lot of complaints with it too and
they're kind of nitpicky and because if
you're gonna bash anything Sony a lot of
times you have to get the kind nitpicky
cuz yeah even they're worse as everybody
else's best native goodness so so days
gone I found really
but there's a lot of themes that were
jarring like whenever you whenever you
go from game played to cutscene in
gameplay seamless like or you know
obviously so dizzy show up to Show and
Tell 786 King takes you out of the
experience and then I'm a sucker for you
know like you said limb separation and
bullet damage and it has has some fairly
decent bull of damage whatnot but
sometimes don't make sense like whatever
you're shooting that big giant thing
that won't remember they call it but
it's like looks like simple tune like
you're just painting like alright you
know that kind of stuff
gets on my nerves but overall I think
the story is better than the average
triple-a game but that's not you know so
USA is like a B title instead of a a
title oh for sure yeah it's okay it's
definitely that the score that it got on
APD's makes total sense but when you
consider the fun factor at least for me
I'd give it an 8 but the score actually
makes sense because the technical
difficulty is the loading if sometimes
the what I call slowdown is horrendous
so yeah what is kind of like it's kind
of like somebody's corner break yeah
look what happened listen what happened
two days gone by the way King I don't
great you know I'm not gonna say it's
the best game right but what happens to
this game is it had it ran into the Last
of Us factor mm-hmm because so many
people are anticipating last of us - oh
okay I don't want to play anything else
in else we'll be able to live up to the
way you
Marvel hustling mobile to follow super
chat I see I got BG in here also I'm
enjoying the podcast don't you know try
to make it seem like oh it's because it
is if if days gone head dropped on Xbox
[Applause]
gamer to you contenders on Xbox it would
have been it would have been best game
but also I think Xbox is held at a
different type of standard real low
and what happened to you people are
really lash out when it comes to
Microsoft so I understand why now it has
to be we got to buy him and make him
shut up about I feel that you know Phil
had to say you know what I'm thinking
tired of dudes talking I'm sick and
tired of the traction yo you need
internet you need intern I got an
Internet for you so I'm all about you
know come out here with the Oprah
Winfrey handing out the Internet
everybody and everybody 20:19 Sony SVG
was and I actually I don't like
comparing you know I don't like the
comparison of comparing that days and
all its equality break kick him back off
that quantum break gameplay was fun the
only thing like be the only ones Rick is
fun this is way more fun factor this is
God your version I love it Metacritic is
the corner of birthdays gone probably
caught a break 72 so I will say I will
tell you this right we're on a break did
not get a sequel we know without a doubt
days prom will begin to seek
motivationally and that word back to the
church we may try something right and if
it doesn't the first one doesn't knock
it out the park
you got something to work with right you
know on a break got a 77 okay there was
no Xbox so that was
one thing is going got me out here
you're sounding like a hypocrite because
well when it comes to any original game
any original IP I'm like every original
IP deserves a sequel to make it better
days long as the first game I'm like I
don't want another one what is it about
days gone that you don't see the
foundation there for a future sequel I'm
curious like what is it about the
gameplay I just think that they can find
ok what one part of it is it is - what
like Kratos said um it's not necessarily
because of the Last of Us I think they
need to find their own lane what
happened when the hold zombie and you
know you can name them three kur
speakers recurs whatever you want to
call it okay the the the zombie game has
been mastered by others
there's nothing original originality is
a little bit overrated well we'll say
that but there's there literally the
only redeeming factor and in this game
is the hordes it's the what was the
movie ten weeks later twenty days was
the second ok that's the only redeeming
factor is the hordes and I just don't
feel like you know this is the game that
Sony Ben should have landed on when they
were trying to find their their
masterpiece you know gorillas they they
found horizon you know you know of
course the Naughty Dog is on the last of
us and you know and all these other
Studios found their thing to work on and
it was and it was beautifully theirs
right this just seems like any studio
could have made this literally any
studio
it could cable them well I agree with
that this was a game that only think
about it was running on Unreal Engine
right um yes anybody could have made
this game I'll give him that
again I did I'm not gonna say that this
game is anywhere near we need other top
two games and that's why picture was
kind of thrashed a lot was because of it
and being keep in mind the game was
buggy as hell yeah it really was they
delayed the game though they've been
patching the game every day I'm gonna
get a good game when it's already
patched no okay so like I've been
playing the game like you know weeks in
between means I've been busy so every
leg is it's like every week or two they
release like almost like a major patch
and you know I usually I beat games
before like I really really get to a
major patch this one I've been able to
see the progress of patches oh and it's
really no different
you still run into bugs after you know
after every patch with the AI is throat
ration and I'm very forgiving when it
comes to bugs I expect you know bugs and
open-world games I'm not the guy like
you know you see but when it's just like
commonplace I'm like okay you you see in
this like every father that you needed
he needed more time to cook at that
exact not yeah the quality control was
not there for this game which has been
something that Sony kind of prided
himself on with that with a lot of their
games look at you know horizon zero dawn
got a war spider-man pain they weren't
they were not broken games and I have
ran into issues with days gone where I
didn't play the game for a whole week
because there was a bug in it that kept
me recaptured from aggressive I saw some
weird glitch that he was trying to climb
between like a light post and a car and
if you threw way up in the air like he's
playing battle royale game yo get out
finish off the day's gonna thing then we
got to get the lords as far as Sony
because I see I mean I was just I'm just
curious to these other fraudulent
PlayStation gamers but does it matter to
you in the developer has got a small
team
because like one remedy they are
extremely small in comparison to other
developers and so in my opinion well it
for me anyway I give I give a lot of
pass like ok when it comes to like the
order for instance well no people no one
gave that same criticism to state it ok
all I did no one said it's a small t no
we kid that's Mira you stay away that
game I never you know it's made by small
group people just like the order the
order wasn't majority made by 22 people
until Santa Monica came in and then
handed him like I think it was like 88
total developers so I mean the order as
good as that game look still holds up it
was made about 20 people so to me well I
wouldn't going into a review I kind of
keep that stuff in the back of my mind
because you know to me that kind of
stuff matters and what they did with
days gone an open-world game with a
hundred people that's quite remarkable
no so that's just much you want to get
it let's get the super chair real quick
can we get it to the lowest def singer
the lat oh come on their singer The Last
of Us is overrated in my opinion got out
to cyberpunk and CD Projekt gods also
actually reassure to come on stage your
bed to be to fill at III salute your
pettiness most def singer all right
let's get Lord attic in here state of
Sony what do you feel in world coming in
20 nights me how you feel about 2019 is
a little Rufe spooky oh yeah I think
though the straighten up to this [ __ ] by
the end of the year
um I do think that it was a mistake
tonight Eva at least be have a for
presence at e3 they didn't have to do a
present but I think a presentation but I
do think you not even showing up to the
floor with your third-party titles and I
mean obviously there's certain games
that that should be at least playable by
now I do think that's disrespectful to
your fan base that's going to either
fair enough fair enough Lord solve how
you feeling now it's status only 2019
how we feeling on Sonia
Emme soft and slow man I mean you hear
me hey you know what the heck no we can
yes
how come it's been slow man I got to say
like you know apart from the show when
days gone that's pretty much it because
if it's not your primary console not
putting your dirt ball or do you know is
there it's been slow oh but my part
yeah I agree about the e3 stuff I think
they should be there I mean if they
don't have they don't have anything they
want to talk about yet in terms of new
stuff yeah it doesn't make sense to have
a presentation but definitely have a
presence there and show off you know
give give your third-party partners a
platform to show off this stuff right
and you know so they don't have to run
off to Microsoft didn't able to show
this stuff all I'm and for the rest of
the year I think I mean honestly I think
they kind of folded up shop I mean
honestly the unless we get you know Last
of Us this year which i think is gonna
happen um everything else I'm looking
forward to like I'm willing to wait to
play it as a cross platform may would
have come in come on cuz you break it in
a little bit I don't think we're getting
last was to this year I don't think
there's no way that I think I think we
are in the breaker cuz next year yes
favi now they would have made at e3 if
they were announcing released e1 and I'm
gonna tell you why they wouldn't right
at the end of the day The Last of Us is
eight I mean just any naughty dog game
that's a cult following that's
guaranteed to give you a minimum of 10
to 15 million they don't have to have
billboards and stuff all over the world
they had to do other games ROM and
that's just what it is they can listen
we all known this poundin they can shut
down the whole III to release date in a
trailer it's over
I think people talk about it a lot but I
don't think you would overshadow e3
because in the fact that we already
noted it's coming to really know that
it's baked there's already know what
we're gonna see this they
shut it down with showing new stuff as
far as shut it down um but as far as a
grabbing a piece of the news cycle no
days it would definitely get a big share
of the news cycle if they give you the
release date because people can
anticipate that day now just like you
said I believe that day that the game
comes out is gonna sell tell me ten
million I'm gonna buy it um so I'm gonna
be playing it oh so I honestly believe
that part but as far as shut down III
know you're gonna have to have more
consistency with two to shut down the e3
you're literally gonna announce
something and then like four hours later
another conference goes and it's been
shut off
like I said Sony's real good at their
panties no I would not put it past them
to announce it during Michaels over a
nap yeah I think after the conference
because the point is is they don't want
the media going at this individual times
they want them at the same time because
they want their their outlet they want
that release date to overshadow right
what's being talked about at the
conference off you do it during the
conference by the time the actual news
comes out if you start putting out the
information it's not even a matter you
know what we're not we're not get into
the semantics attic of the actual time
like that of the day winning you know
we've got 140 people go and hit that
like like though for really I'm curious
what the chair has to say put a 1 if you
think last of us is coming out this year
put a 2 if you don't think it'll put it
in colors because I can't
I don't think it's coming out this year
I think I think Naughty Dog is very
capable they have one of the biggest
studios and one of the largest stacks
and the truth that's not true for an
offer for the so nice to know the first
part we all know I don't think it's
coming out this year not because they're
not capable they can definitely grind
and you know they have the talent and
the numbers to get it done and release
it by like October November but I don't
think they even want to release it in
October they don't like doing it they
love that spring Tom Daley into several
crunches this year though just as an
example right they love that spring
tithe is coming out spring next year and
like by that time yeah I don't think get
it close okay and so so then what if
it's not coming out this year BD Dan
what do you think they used to push
consoles and fall I don't think they
have we're in the endgame we're talked
about five now if it's for the relevant
displayed showing the difference in
loading time between the console they
really care about the ps4 selling that
much more anymore like it's in did it
surpass everybody's expectation you know
it's only not gonna pass the the ps2
that's it so I don't really think they
care about the sales of it that much
anymore
no no doubt Lord King you want to get
your state it's only real quick
all right well this this year's let me
see
I was really anticipating days long and
regardless of what anybody says I'm
gonna purchase the game anyway and I'm
gonna play the game and I'm gonna enjoy
the game for what it's worth because
what I saw about the game actually
intrigued me to the point that I can
knock out the noise now um I I like what
Sony has done so
far this year the state of play uh so
excited place that your five might be
2021 I believe yes so excited sorry is
coming next year mm-hmm
so PS 5s coming at you know I think it's
early 2021 imagine if if they do come
out in 2021 and xbox strong next year
like do you think that would help XW
have senses it would be a death since
because all they would need is something
that's naughty but there has been times
a bit they're coming out sooner helps a
lot here in a hey like a year later
after the 360 but on top of launching a
year later in without rumbling inferior
tech they can't launch inferior tech a
year later oh yeah you gonna tell me
that it's not gonna be infuriating I do
believe that anaconda will be more
powerful but here's pain right now the
world's weakest console to switch
there's power does not matter when it
comes to going we have to be a fourth
row and look at the X right
well now the X is more powerful back in
the day the Pro has the games it has it
has the benchmark horizon zero dawn
spider-man date and and you know day is
going in all these games you want to
play about to showcase we got the X in
all and all we got to show for it is a
bunch of multiplets
running in 4k
any more than that they need more than
we're not gonna step back from
resolution we're gonna attack resolution
like we said I'm native okay is a big
thing that is the big thing that it is
and we sit back and talk about
resolution don't matter when it mattered
before boarding Sony's checkerboarding
in their games look way better on my TV
and I got games that like Red Dead been
smoking my real poor King and it's so
it's sub 4k is that reason akimbo with
the xbox one sad edition I'm premium I
didn't even hit it to my section you can
you can skip native 4k when you are
really reaching for a baby I got my Z
man G and gonna be unboxed so look out
for air aka baby front if you brought it
for that PlayStation you might as well
take it back to the store right there I
felt at Sony's a state of plate it's
fantastic and they adopted and they
listened to the the criticisms of Xbox
show right and they they stay actually
just give you games and they put it out
sometimes it's not good but this is how
they're gonna trickle information to you
so because they don't have an e3 right
right so the way that they're doing in a
piece mailing it to you they're giving
you fan service without disappearing
from the whole
the new cycle right so I believe going
in this year like everybody's don't
bagging on days going but I honestly
believe that that was a good game to set
up the Last of Us for the end of the
year think the Last of Us sets up for
the end of the year I hold I guess I got
attic and then I guess it's got attic
you want to say something and I'm like
so Scott you know just to bounce off a
little bit on the resolution talking
like I do think that for the past couple
Jin's mm-hmm resolutions really mattered
at the beginning but I don't think it's
best to persona I don't know what's
gonna be available at launch like I
don't know what their processes I don't
maybe we'll get our horizon zero dawn
sequel 1407 yeah shut up I don't
particularly Sony I don't think power is
gonna be as big as a place that's has
been in the past couple gins because
they've never had this kind of a stack
when it comes to games going into a
generation up until now
okay fair enough so Scott you up and
then I want to finish this point on
state of uh Sony so addicted to elves I
don't know what that guy's ever talking
about spreads misinformation but Lord of
Lord of the statues I have a question
since a lot of green coming from you
yeah take you seriously when you still
playing destiny understand a real good
quality game faces
let me let me explain let me let me give
you my defensive destiny it's sold more
than any game that you won't put up
so whatever game that was your game of
the year last year my game is still
being played all right
so pull up I got you baby let me jump
never could get off this day's garden
that's really bad finish with the
stateís Tony McMahon at the end of the
day look they stood a de facto for us
any chance that the hardware sales you
don't say it's awful sales is do
anything you know mean to me they old
cruise control right they you already
know last year like cradle said they had
to God of War they had to spine you know
I'm saying day's going is kind of solid
but not for everybody but I mean they
think to me know the elephant in the
room and I don't think a lot of people
won't give it credit and solve will
agree is your switch right I don't we
keep making this an Xbox thing but
they've kind of taken over in Japan man
their home country you know I'm saying
like where they started I mean then the
last 5mp DS Nintendo switch has one
don't say
yeongman can we make that yes so knees
at the end of the life cycle I get that
part but I don't want them to
underestimate coming into the next gen
you know Nintendo as a competitor you
know me so that's all pretty much I got
to say at the end of the day we got it I
want them to kind of finish strong
we'll see what happens but are we gonna
move on to the next ones we got a lot of
heart oh yeah real quick Smitty Smurf
can I get a man I'm still playing that's
me - oh so that's what I'm talking about
that's right the church is essentially
even though be Jesus gotta like alright
so we gonna get into some partnership
talk and you know many some news drop
down see we know about the the cloud
division talk you know the the agreement
with a Sony's AI and um Marx talked
cloud as your servers and we saw Yoshida
we saw such a bonus stage bringing
things together community was in a bit
of a tizzy with Ted and then obviously
we heard the aftermath of that which is
on you know some people with Sony us
management they were blindsided you know
they didn't see this coming you know and
stuff like that and then the third part
of this whole thing was obviously the
recent statements by Ishita and him
saying that the console generation I
mean what consoles in general being
leaked in that kind of secular it is
start itself with cradles you know me
never got a chance to talk about the
partnership so or talk about the
partnership okay about Sony's reaction
internal and then the whole niche thing
so good
give it up though so see what's okay
well I'll tell you what this was
something that nobody can say that you
know my insider source told me this is
gonna happen this happened and you know
with the wee hours of the morning it was
shocking because I don't mean interrupt
you during your talk yeah but I told you
that y'all was gonna bending me I want
you I want you to go back to the last
time use here and I told you
y'all will all form Voltron that's why
the Lions is here right now and I told
y'all that y'all will be a simulated and
you told me when pigs fly I don't want
to know right now look there's no window
is that bacon swinging out there
I'm trying to understand what happened
the demand said a sentence has anything
changed he said a word what change
happened I'm on this time I listen I'm
gonna go ahead let me stop sugarcoating
it this is what this is this is how the
Xbox community see would happen right
you've all think about it for the last
six years you have been in despair
you've lost right you've been getting
molly-whopped for six years so in the
console game in the console space when
it comes to gaming mm-hmm that's a rap
is over and Xbox was already done for
this generation had already moved on to
next generation mm-hmm but what happened
after the last second Mike I'll drop the
money back and now the guys are trying
to make it seem like the last six years
of losing every single inconvenient has
been erased magically erased now here's
the thing about it right what six seven
months no it's been like five months
anymore this is this is why Nintendo
doesn't even come into the fold because
Nintendo had to go into a whole nother
generation in order to even make any
dish yeah do we it's supposed to be
competing with the Xbox one and
PlayStation so let's get that you know
instead of double the whole football I
can do if now if Microsoft would say
look we failed with the Xbox one we're
gonna go ahead and move to the Anaconda
next generation and then we start doing
well that would be that's like with
Nintendo has deal right so but I do give
them them props for starting over and in
calling a failure failure and moving
forward I'll give them that but you
don't get any brownie points when you
already collapsed on a holding product
failure that you know we'll we'll catch
up to them next generation they are
ready in a dictionary
so babe they're not even in the game but
this is what happened right listen here
here's the thing is the switch is about
to move in the second place if you want
to look at it that way being where does
that lead NB its Xbox and oh wait a
second boat as far as Microsoft the
world's richest comes company now I'm
talking about the gaming division I'm
not even talking about what you talking
about I'm just talking about the game of
division your gaming division versus
this gaming division
say that Sony rakes in more revenue with
yes in with games with software hardware
and all that so let me go ahead and
write my thing up so you guys can tell
you so what happened right outside of
the gaming room you had the big boys
talk you know that the CEOs of companies
say look we know we compete when it
comes to gaming and stuff like that but
we are focusing on something else in
business we're talking about cloud which
I we need some sensors we need some
semiconductors you know you guys need
you know a cheaper price because right
now you're paying Amazon all this money
for your PSN and Xbox now
I mean PS now and stuff like that let's
work out some business they had really
nothing to do with gaming but on the
flip side havoc on servers would allow
Sony to implement stuff in within gaming
so that's how that's how it is so it's
not like there's this Xbox takeover of
PlayStation but that's obviously that's
how we spend it right because we joke
going back and forth well uh at the end
of the day I think maybe two years from
now we'll see with what the end result
is gonna be from this partnership if
this even turns out to happen all right
now wolves wolves the second question
that you asked Michelle
without the stitch in the chair of the
phylosophy chair bro stop the Nintendo
slander we talking about real console
why are we the second part is about the
Sony employees not realizing that you
know Courtney's got these made this at
the top level and feeling blindsided
feeling upset like you know how could
John do this how could John go to
Microsoft you know there without letting
us know kind of thing it's scary they're
gonna go over to work and get a pink
slip it's like we don't need you no more
no no no it did I'm gonna tell you what
I'm gonna tell you I that that is kind
of messed up to them because they feel
like look this whole generation we've
been doing everything right we've been
busting our humps right delivering
quality hardware software VR everything
else doing everything right to show
people our platform our ecosystem is the
best place to play and you turn around
behind our backs without us knowing it
could have deal with the competition
without involving us right now people
are like hey you know what the hell oh I
do understand that that's messed up but
I do realize that in the day it's all
about the top dog business it's all
about business ain't no dollar and in
you know you achieve it those are the
two top dogs for the Sony Corporation
and last question sir last question was
your sheet is comment about the consoles
market being nice and yeah you more
upset about that that missing something
is that that is 100% true because they
actually showed the chart mm-hmm and
this is what I don't like right gaming
has always been centered around a
console in its own particular market
right what everybody else is trying to
do it feel Spencer and now you're sheet
are trying to do they're trying to add
other people in who's on the mobile
phones who's on tablets who's on all
kind of stuff yeah we wouldn't consider
game part of the gaming they trying to
mix them into the fold and I'll be you
have billions of those people compared
to a small couple hundred million
actually all console owners and gamers
that's it so right now they're basically
telling us hey we understand we like you
guys but you guys together collectively
only come to be 150 million we're going
these guys who spend $100 a month on
candy crush you know the bigger games
and that's scary to me as a gamer
because I've always been into the
console room ever since Atari 2600 I'm
gonna start catering to those guys and
leaving me no meaning coming with these
little small piecemeal type and/or game
sell that to me for you know for
whatever Kratos there we want to billion
gamers right there just there fish elite
jumping on the Microsoft train wreckage
to broaden the horizons as much as
possible
but that would necessarily Microsoft's
Microsoft didn't didn't start that
obviously a billion people in the world
if Microsoft couldn't get 50 million
people to buy their your console a
bigger scope for two - okay okay they
got a dick is what Phil came on yeah
three ago and he said comment box warn
every device yeah a talking point a lot
of the Annette was like seeing you guys
gonna get games over here and that kind
of so we kind of gotta admit that they
are mimicking Mars true they they are
listen I'll give that up every day of
the week no it's this shock to me this
shock to everybody it doesn't seem like
right now people asking me hey do you
think Sony games are gonna be ever I
can't even tell you
I can't if you asked me two weeks ago I
would've told you no no I'm willing to
say probably yeah because the best way
is going kratos about being that we know
our game past as a foregone conclusion
on that switch um do you think that Sony
would definitely fully just chop off
both leaves and arms and put game pass
on the PlayStation hey that's the thing
about it I can't I honestly cannot say
what Sony wouldn't do at this point
right let's get out BG then we get
ourselves guys BG what do you think am i
right about the partnership you know the
some employ Sony employees feeling
slandered and then the whole niche thing
I mean when it comes to a lot of these
you know statements and deals because I
read something that the partnership was
just like them talking
didn't actually sign to me back ass or
anything yeah so paperwork was done an
agreement understanding you yeah like
honestly it means nothing to me
until like there's some paperwork I only
said it because there's always talk of
like things like this happening to me
this stuff is like it's my trademark you
know how we always get rumors of a
trademark and like 50% of the trademarks
and nothing ever happens mmm that's how
that's that's how I look at this type of
stuff
I mean if someone's happened OBJ's
wasn't the only difference I see I feel
what you're saying because you are right
technically right it is not signed no
one's put anything to paper in an
official sense but not you for tracing
the variety is when we make a an
impression of visual statement of the
head of Sony and the head of Microsoft
now making a picture and a press release
it does feel a little different no
that's what I was gonna say but could
didn't yeah I still feel like okay and
when something does come out of this
like something does come to fruition
it's still gonna be many years away like
as far as like cloud I still you know I
still believe that cloud it being
something that we would that we would
use well over physical media is very far
away doctor physical media actual
physical console will always be the
preferred method like as far as far as I
can see I still think in the next ten
years I feel like I'm not saying it
won't get better right but I don't think
it'll Trump having like a you know
playing something natively yeah like
five to ten years out like this is a
future proofing move yeah it's it's
looking it's investing into it for the
for the future it's it's like how they
you know it's it's research and
development but it's not something for
the right now so I don't really I don't
really care about it the PlayStation the
legislation in Xbox is going to be you
know all it's still gonna be from a
physical you know box and it's it's
honestly you know gonna it's gonna stay
that way for that for the next
generation so I don't really care about
the cloud right now
I think the stadia is gonna be
irrelevant so that tells you how much I
feel about the cloud I think they're
joining is gonna be irrelevant nobody's
against its height its it's a pipe dream
fair enough sport to it a question of
Sony's employees feeling blindsided by
the move on a higher up level at the top
[ __ ] happens well [ __ ] happens bro you
not at the top right hey man maybe maybe
you you didn't have that type of
clearance right maybe I was above your
pay grade
what about their employment BG what a
man y'all make these games it was it was
nothing it was nothing in this paperwork
that said we will tell you all everybody
knows I'm not the most heartfelt person
when it comes to you see this coming
about the cousin what you're being mich
Mich yeah it is well you when you look
at it from you know like a hundred
million isn't a lot when we think about
what could be you know of all the people
in the world that could be playing on a
console could be playing video games
mom it's from the perspective of what
consoles have done in the past 100 100
million is good you know that that's
based on the comparison right but yeah I
don't have a problem with what he said
and I don't think it I think it's a big
deal I don't think it like makes any
difference either way like why is this
even like a people when they feel it
yeah it was such a big topic you said it
was like ok what does that change what
is that what does that mean hmm for
gaming hmm fair enough
Lord silver needs your feeling on here
we go
we were feeling on on this whole mob
understanding before Marcus parkinsonian
and then you know Sony employees feeling
blindsided by this move of them trying
to link with the cloud as your servers
let me start off by staying
hold on my wife is holed up knows go
away woman called this in 2014 and a
video called riding on the wall and and
I spelled it out with pie charts and
graphs and what have you so it was very
detailed on why Microsoft's gonna do
with their did we now know so and I also
like to say the whole play anywhere
thing was not stolen by Sony it was the
other way around because PlayStation now
was already a full operation before Xbox
even announced that so yeah there's that
ok and the way I view it is that let me
see I think that they are they started
the dialogue hey why are you still
holding up should I turn Oh with all the
games streaming does this mean that Xbox
play anywhere becomes obsolete Microsoft
is trying to be on all devices no no I
think I think the reason why they
actually got together it started a
dialogue was because they are trying to
combat the actual 800-pound gorilla
which is Amazon Armas and
yeah yeah anyone ever claim they're
playing the long game and I'm smart so
and I don't think in that video I was
talking about how Microsoft as a company
and their their entire mantra if you
will is to be agnostic when it comes to
hardware
they want their software on me devices
as possible and so it only makes sense
for them to become some sort of
third-party support for everybody and
what I mean by that is I I visioned back
in 2014 when I made the video that they
would implement their Azure cloud as an
example to work with everybody and it's
only gonna help boost the gaming
industry I think it's good for everybody
I don't see it as a negative and whether
or not you know we'll see Halo and Gears
and stuff on PlayStation to me it's all
irrelevant III don't
I think pet Sony's a little petty when
it comes to that sort of things I don't
think that will happen necessarily but I
just need as good news I don't see
that's a bad Oh old Sony is petty when
it comes in that regard I think once new
people was put in position it was more
palatable to what's to come
gosh and last thing are the silver as
far as the whole new thing is that over
radar people overreacting no I think
that's a way to frame how you attack the
next generation so if you if you look at
it like oh how are we supposed to
duplicate 100 million consoles you get
kind of overwhelmed by it if you frame
it as this is a niche thing and we need
to quit looking at this as a we're
trying to reach as many people as
possible instead we're gonna hone in on
the ninjin root and really maximize our
results from last generation I think
it's just way too framing how you go
into the next generation I wouldn't read
too much into it it's more of like just
get people talking like we are right now
no down big corporate sweet lord addict
are you dear sir so you might newton i
don't know if he's bet you may step away
for a second let's get lord saw I'm here
okay attic what's up man so what you
feeling about the partnership and stuff
like that and and then the whole niche
team Sony doesn't I think Sony's like
half foot half foot out they they see
the trend they think you can go that way
but at the same time they were like we
don't want to invest
in case it doesn't go that what oh so
they're like so what what's the
best-case scenario most people they hire
people to do stuff like that so you
don't have to you know they're back when
VR was gonna go on xbox people were you
know giving Microsoft a lot of credit
was like okay used by so you don't have
to make your own right you don't have to
invest Millie no no I got that thing
called Halloween you know I think that's
what this is a case of I think that they
do think it's gonna go that way but they
don't want to invest our own money into
that kind of service because in case it
doesn't and to be fair maybe they don't
really have the capital to invest in
just something like that there's an
awful lot of money to make that well
it's like a billion dollars of every
station that does cloud computing for
Microsoft mm-hmm like it's not cheap
they did have more options I've kind of
curious why they move Microsoft may be
in the better deal that's what we're
getting today when I talk to that's an
interesting point
all right so and what about the hold
initiative people are reacting when she
said it I personally think people
reacted by at the same time this is the
internet Sony should have realized
something like that would have annoyed a
couple people no doubt no doubt
Oh Oh real quick - I'm King but I wanted
to ask you I forgot to ask you out is
and just go to be G&G know what do you
think if Phil Spencer would have saved
consoles with these hope he would have
made a big deal out of it - people would
have been would have been like talking
about I think we would have had people
like Kratos exactly on Twitter's like yo
man if I would've said bestow but it
would have been the name change you know
that would be the name change for crater
in each box you know that remember like
when I was they oh they people always
attach to these certain words that these
execs use in their statement
what was it scarce when these are the
appeal Oh sparse most wash station
always an executor gotta be careful I
don't think it's a wrong with the word
he used
just know whatever word you use people
are always gonna make it negative and
like highlight the word and make it as
big big this is why you know for example
like you got feel Aaron Greenberg Mike
Ibarra those guys are always on Twitter
right you never really see Shawn Layden
a Yoshida nobody from Sony camp in the
know on Twitter about you know I'm
seeing about stuff so so Sony probably
date they don't they don't know what's
going on in Twitter streets in this
whole console war thing oh you should
say to Sonia internet-savvy
understand a little bit more about how
to internet work they are thoroughly
aware of how people talking about their
products and their stuff they are the
masters of marketing to the ps4 Profeta
for K days gone scoring lower than fan
abducts they need Xbox is the best box
shout out to Phil Dominus well you know
we got a hundred and thirty people
definitely that like button being lazy
just hit the boy
having a good time well it'll hit the
hit that button and Craig Kratos will
become Xbox car I donated a X symbol on
my chest
no I'm sure would answer my shirt on but
halftime I'm going to rip it off with me
Kratos there yeah you know what's funny
those fan face they actually make you
wear certain things almost every I don't
know if they did it last year so you're
gonna wear something like it's about the
greatest the crazy Kratos doesn't care
about that stuff right the cradles we
put on the Xbox shirt like he said he's
down for the bidding I thought the top
dollar paid for his way so he's at fan
fest and they definitely gonna pay his
way so he's gonna definitely be a X by
that date but um like what you were
saying like it kind of kind of perplexed
me because you told me they was internet
selling but Internet stupid at the same
time and I'm just trying to figure out
where are they really yet because making
statements like that would certify on
the Internet right but also you said
they were smart enough to make that
statement so they they would there was a
plan stupid and it made the statement Oh
or were they really so smart that they
tricked them into thinking it was not I
mean this is what happened right you
gotta realize that that Yoshida not
Shuhei Yoshida okay but I think it's
Cantera kingster AAG yeah you're sure he
need is new in that particular role that
he's in you know in making statements
right he hasn't been necessarily the
mouthpiece it's always been somebody
else so he goes out there he has to
speak for all of Sony that means Sony
movies Santi it's only uh music
everything he has to speak from that
standpoint but that's why you don't let
those particular guys have the
microphone every time you know if you
ask that rep and PlayStation I mean
Yoshi Yoshida mark Cerny every everybody
else they know they station all the way
where
the other you cheated the head guy he's
like yeah I like where you said those
honey all the way those are the guys
that didn't get the memo - they're
switched and some noes are not - guys I
don't hate it even came shout even the
Microsoft team didn't even know as well
you know that this is this is David in
Kratos you know at the bar having having
a drink
be a man's man couldn't appeal without
the wives and the kids and everything
what do you feel about this whole thing
with the partnership and initiative
before like this is this is born with
the devil that you know and the devil
that you know against the devil that you
don't know and that's regardless of how
people feel about stadia and how close
we are to actual real cloud integration
of stuff backwards they got you know a
boatload of money but they're gonna
spend on it and and they're they're
coming regardless you know how
successful they are not they come in so
why not I would you know I'd prefer that
the big three in gaming side with each
other and you know form some custom
Voltron amongst themselves and you know
and use Microsoft Azure it's so to me
from a business perspective it's perfect
oh no the nice thing no I'll wait on the
niche thing the whole thing about this
only employees being pissed off yeah I
mean again you your worker be your
worker be you not privy to to what some
a great so like BG said like listen you
know you have to go over whatever the
big boys decide and that's it now one
thing I do question a little bit is that
you gotta be careful about the morale
right like when you if if they were so
blindsided by this that means that the
the atmosphere there was like gun holds
only screw Microsoft's us-versus-them
that's what it felt like because why
would you react to that why would you
react like unless I'm changing the mic
so unless you know unless the the
atmosphere at Sony is us versus them
so I can see people something we've been
feeling betrayed by that right and and
and who knows how that affects the
studio sell for PlayStation as a whole
um you gotta be careful with stuff like
that I understand I get you know
decisions are made at the top that
you're not privy to you don't have any
input on what when it's been when it's
something like this that's always been
this this competition typically with one
opponent it's you know it can be jarring
that all of a sudden now we're you know
we're kind of on the side I don't know
how that pans out but I think it should
have been handled a little bit better
and the nice stuff gaming who is beneath
it in the very beginning has been neat
and if things now is that the goalpost
is move like if we take the amount of
consoles and people playing games now
and you transplant that or ten years ago
all of a sudden that's Main Street have
you talking about nearly 200 million
consoles out there now you talk
mainstream ten years ago now because
nobody was thinking about reaching
billions upon billions of people you
know on a phone on on the on the web
with the cloud and stuff like that that
wasn't that wasn't something that was a
prevalent thought so now that goalpost
is moved so now being we fall into the
niche category was like okay you guys
you guys are cool you guys sort of drive
the conversation around gaming because
we do we're doing it right now
but at the end of the day you know you
only matter those first ten million
sales those first ten million sales of
any console generation is you guys is us
after that how do we get the other you
know 100 million people in that we want
to get in right yeah and that's see that
that's the what they're trying to figure
out and that's why we'll always be in
each will always be the driving factor
behind the tech and behind what what
what's most exciting about these
consoles but at the end of the day you
know once those first 10 million is sold
yeah it's how you get that dude that
doesn't game every single day to buy
your machine or to buy into your
ecosystem
are you uh oh I am yeah I mean that's my
primary could you just said a whole lot
of words with very little context
but it's explained is no SideReel the
CEO doesn't think they can reproduce the
overall success of the ps4 tempering
expectations before the generation even
starts that might be a little bit close
to their mindset wrath of war with the
final assuage FPS more bending those
Ashley needs the secret Bush tattoo or
their chests don't have the balls to
come III yet Nintendo and Xbox are going
and the jamya Dixon with the file I said
that your brother next-gen will be more
of the same and all of this will be
forgotten
both fanboys need to go sit down and
worry about paying for online pc master
race between you a disagreement what
solve understand why is that sir in this
said basically he was going on on just
droning and droning the drink like you
know III a lot it just bigs
you know a lot of words very little
actual we're exclusive you know with
some the marketing terms they use world
premiere but visiting selves got what
specifically do you disagree with what
Saul was saying have an issue English
that's cool you don't this is a problem
I understand so you finish all the
questions for me please so I know how to
attack this yeah man so pretty much like
I say
remain obviously we know what happened
between a Microsoft and Sony with the
cloud Azure and the AI and then you know
obviously they're the employees somebody
on a middle to lower level being upset
being blindsided and then the whole
statement is fine you Sheeta about
consoles being itch all right so first
of all let's start off with this
agreement the agreement that I knew that
was coming
like I told people and everybody's like
King you're crazy like you're crazy it's
not gonna happen and I was like yo knees
will be mine and they're gonna track
like and I and I got all our respect for
Lord Field Dominus Spencer um and I knew
visually when I told you he was Xing out
those dudes on stage and he's the last
man standing on that stage when he
stepped on a stage he knew that dude was
gone and that dude was gone and dudes
laughed at me and said no way Reggie's
out of here principal and all of respect
much do the Reggie Reggie that's crazy
respect on that you were not bending the
knee Reggie said this is not gonna
happen on my watch I'm out of here
and um and as far as what that was Laden
that was in position on the side not out
Andru house yes yes I don't mean knowing
them dudes because they don't make
yourself available and will be hiding in
the bushes peeking a little face on the
only wanna give out numbers when it's
gonna get 100 that's a fact that's the
fact is 100 million but we're making the
same money um now this this is the part
right here the part that makes sense
with Microsoft when y'all was building
100 million Microsoft who's building
workstations mm-hmm right when y'all was
gettin it up yeah I was like yeah we out
here tearing up these streets Microsoft
was like you gonna need my son and they
was out there building up these
workstations
so you can actually have good internet
because y'all know if y'all play on a
Playstation 4 y'all understand what is
like is like you're playing on a
Playstation 3
I got a PlayStation 4 I'm I go front I
don't like the Internet and we don't
like these services and we gonna keep it
true now game pass is definitely
surpassed y'all when it comes to online
gaming services I was out first right
that's what I said yeah I was out there
first
yeah y'all ash you're dead last please
go home for your Knittle ass right now
so um but it's not us versus dumb
because your team now mm-hmm so it's not
us versus dumb it's not it's it's we
versus the world
no instead I got to change Phil's name
from Phil Dominus to Phil bold you have
been assimilated those trying to fight
it off for as long as I can fight it off
but y'all realized at the end of the day
we're all one team we all one squad got
all will rep the X so I do appreciate
the fact that the cloud gaming and all
Internet services will definitely be
provided to you by our Xbox and is a
good thing because we know the Xbox Live
is far superior than their PlayStation
stuff and I like going forward would it
look like I love what it go for look
like now as far as that niche thing if
Phil would have said that niche thing
the internet would have blew up because
when he said single-player games were a
thing of the past or something something
I forgot what he said but he phrase you
say I'll tell you what he said tell me
what he said he says single-player story
driven games don't cut it anymore they
don't only say yeah you're right like
when you looked at it because Sony
that's the whole joint single play
experiences in the corner not they're
not about what they strengths aren't and
the extremes weren't multiplayer stuff
so you're gonna talk about a company
whose strengths is multiplayer and
inclusion and you're talking about a
company that is seclusion right so of
course their views of it will be
different but when Phil steps out then
he's visible like you said a lot of
these microsoft expects are visible and
there seemed so the words carry weight
and now the fact that this blindsided a
lot of people when he said it was niche
because y'all thought y'all was top of
the food chain
yo Joe was bigger the biggest right so
when he said I was niche that minimized
you and people don't like being
minimized so that's why the internet
went into a tizzy because I think you
could t respond they didn't like being
on yeah go for me go become a man I
thing okay miss mr. Johnson yes you you
talk a lot about bend the knees but
aren't you like 12 foot 13 okay so you
have like so so based on common sense
you have blackbaud knees so the only
person that needs you now stop here's
the thing so Xbox what they did was they
realized that they can't beat Sony so
they're like screw it we'll join them
how is this negative not the other way
around I'm gonna tell you why business
why is not the other way around right
sony has already became dominant in
gaming this is what they had no need to
go to e3 when you don't have any
competition in that specific real there
is no need to do putting loaded
exclusives they're gonna show up with a
bunch of multiplex yeah we'll be playing
on a Playstation and a switch and peace
in everything else so but but Microsoft
damn right
Microsoft is focusing on cloud in there
as your servers right there cloud based
business yeah but their focus on that
they've already failed when it comes to
the class it was a console generation
date they barely pushing 40 okay sorry
they have 50 stop that alright so what
we're gonna do is listen I got I got a
robot something with you okay because
you definitely you know major statement
it was killed you're not going to eat me
because you've got no games but if
you're going to eat me because Microsoft
said come join us cuz they got games now
Microsoft went out and brought Studios
you said they were worried about the
cloud note it was one of a multi-faceted
right so Sony only focused need zero DNA
cat game it a year right zeroed in
Microsoft said we're gonna spread it out
we're gonna make sure that this cloud of
gaming is up because these dudes gonna
need it soon so we got to have a strong
back to put them on right so now that my
isn't it a good thing that Microsoft was
worrying about those clouds stuffing
isn't it a good thing
you would have been under Google right
now Amazon right now right but you like
the way s Scotties you made it a comment
that a lot of people seem to matter as
far as this whole who came to whom and
all this stuff so let me ask you this in
reference to Sony I apologize
yeah Jason le he said how do they clean
up the online experience you can't
always play with people you know the
harassment is real I feel that
definitely gotta clean up but subscribe
just what actually is in reference to
Sony's infrastructure from a cloud
standpoint you felt that they didn't
come to mark so they didn't need that
improvement to future-proof themselves
I'm confused on that part we would all
be speculating so I won't say anything
else facts none of us know I will say
that they bought Gaikai and they have
more direct mm-hmm individual servers
dedicated to gaming then mark saw I held
that because of freedom
I should see this is going to sound like
I have an insider okay here's here's the
thing it has nothing to do with game
this guy he he owns his own cloud
services type company and he on a
regular basis goes out to Microsoft's
when they call those things where the
underground don't it's like a huge
football stadium of just servers a lot
of what Xbox Live is is when they call
it's not dedicated server it's as your
dedicated servers dumb confused prior to
prior to Azure because answer was in the
makes for in the works for a long time
prior to that Xbox Live was primarily
I'm just getting the term it's a virtual
virtual servers weren't dedicated to
Xbox Live like they mislead you to
believe
Xbox is full of fake news the point the
point is that the PlayStation already
you know dove into the dedicated servers
a long time ago
they just allocated it to the wrong area
they didn't put it into PSN it's not
integrated with PSN like it should have
been a long time ago it was more
dedicated PlayStation now which to me
was a bad move all right I'm gonna let
this really eager to tennis sorry oh you
know someone first okay which has sony
binds to
girls as well for next-gen song spying
studios yeah the ten dollar super chat
sorry but that's a bunch of stupidity so
many like many other companies are now a
customer of margasoft sure Sony sought
more hardware guess what Microsoft still
made more money than Sony off software
what did that what did that money get
you this generation it got shot because
we're not in other business dealings and
camera lenses and sensors and I'll speak
on that right after but we're here for
the game right and at the end of the day
you know Sony can get in bed with
Nintendo and Google and whoever it's all
think he provided me them big mega
hitting Game of the Year continuous
that's all I care about but at the
flipside you know it seems like people
focusing in on these servers in not
humor sensors the semiconductor oh it
makes it seem like oh well Microsoft is
getting getting famous Leone and not
what Sony is able to sell okay all right
um cradles to answer your thing like in
any type of partnership it has to be a
give-and-take right it can't be you know
we're just gonna provide you this
services like that you know I honestly
believe and I hope just to be true I
wanted to get back to how it used to be
where you know um gaming was a feel like
you know you you felt like if he had a
PlayStation you can go over this house
and you can play it and do you had your
Nintendo or whatever it was [ __ ]
they gotta get to that space because I
don't care what anybody say um those
White Walkers is real that situation is
real yeah if Netflix decides tomorrow
that they want to jump into gaming you
know they had the platform to reach you
so these things is real and you don't
want to lose out on what it is so I
understand I have to deal with each
other and they're gonna have to share
tech through so don't don't think that
Mike
often just out here purchasing these
dudes or you know getting a check from
Sony to get down with them know did
there's a partnership involved in this
and they will be sharing technology with
each other I don't agree let me say this
real quick I agree with that a thousand
percent David you know I'm gonna tell
you why and I will go there because I
think somebody in the chat probably
mentioned it earlier
yes Microsoft and Sony and Nintendo see
Google as the big boogeyman guys think
about it
these Google owns the internet owns in
it they already in everybody's household
get Microsoft trying to be in the
household Google is already in your
household yeah oh they they figure if
Apple in Google and all these other guys
these big people who are able to come in
and take all of our power take all of
our food we all got to eat - at the end
of the table we got to eat at the table
together so we band together because
like you said console gaming is niche
there are two of two billion other
mediums out there and ways to get money
so maybe this is why it's like hey we'll
put all the charades aside right well
we're gonna pan together right now to
keep these big giants White Walkers from
coming in and in taken destroyed in that
super super chat he said Trump's taking
about 25% tax bills on our favorite
gaming console today gaming arcade
podcast had a lot of info on that
subject thank you for the suture we're
not gonna get into the politic aspect
but we do recognize which say in Philly
Eagle finalist which I last day play
what you want
stop being a fanboy we don't play sales
we play games and all the games I like
and look better on my xbox okay was that
the case prior to the X oh all his games
on on the Xbox prior to the X came out
coming out 7720 glory without the
bleeding eyes oh yeah making good points
oh yeah I mean look at the end of the
day in my parents all he's doing is a
forward thinking more like the guy cut
acquisition I know what you I know what
you're trying to go that's God but at
the end of the day it was never a true
performance solution Oh
the cognitive structure of what Asher is
doing and where the gaming is going and
that's gonna be the streaming you know I
mean so you even got to go one two three
put one two three place you gotta go to
that Asher you gotta go to Amazon or you
got to go to Google like on credit
saying those are the three best to quit
for the end game especially if screaming
he's gonna take off in another what five
to ten years or whatever it is that it
actually you know gets to that point
with you know market penetration 5g low
latency yadda yadda yadda two billion is
the goal and I'm saying now what's
interesting to me is I'm surprised that
Sony didn't go with Amazon no that
surprised me so to me when I see that
that to me is a testament to how
impressed they were with Microsoft Azure
it boils down to the money cuz they they
said Microsoft's as your service was
ninety four percent cheaper Indian right
now they're currently with Amazon right
yes now they're currently with that but
the cost of that is astronomical
right so they're looking for the long
haul if Microsoft if we can partner with
these guys at a ninety four percent
discount I mean probably even cheaper
since we're gonna be exchanging ticking
meeting little minds and stuff like that
yeah that's I mean that makes it that's
coming it makes a money game it's a
money on a big level I feel what you go
with that the only thing I would say is
that it is interesting because it's like
if you future puching yourself proof
like yourself you guess you saving and
then also you're doing this exchange you
give me you know the AI and the image
sensors and all that stuff I completely
see what you're going with that it's
just interesting cuz obviously you know
they're going with the enemy they know
when I'm saying and listen at the end of
day all I care about Kratos all I care
about those guys is at the end of the
day if they are all on this as your
backbone we gonna get that cross play or
you gonna get that cross progression you
know I'm saying it well we got you know
but at the end of a to me as gaming or
that that excite me online communities
being together and to me when you see
stuff like fortnight and Dauntless in
the early stages of what cross played
can be with all these communities
playstation xbox pc switch all playing
together that to me
there's no excuse now because everyone
okay okay look let me see this right
over here this is what scares me right
talk with tears me is the other day we
had Xbox Live now now you throw in a
hundred million other users hundred
fifty million other users throw on that
now when it goes down we all down the
map people have problems this hangout
with Google survey will just spread more
fake news if you follow xbox support and
patient support
Xbox Live is down much more regular
basis the right way we also want to talk
about cloud as your as your
infrastructure is for more far-reaching
and way more superior than Gaikai 90% of
your user base is on it like I can't say
that for police station okay so you
gonna send me uh what what's the
percentage these people a lot of
PlayStation but they not online they
just they say there was 94 million PS
Plus accounts active engaging with the
file are supporting AWS servers are
awful anyway most these are free to play
games or query servers is use of us
source I suffered through Ark for years
okay must be what dauntless is on to
make me wait for 30,000 people to get on
that I have a question how come I can
get online without any wait time because
there ain't nobody there
with no weight there's nobody playing it
to be fair there's more people playing
The Last of Us and uncharted
multi-layered then people that are
playing crackdown 3 there's actually a
lot of people playing that game is that
multiplayer is so slept on you like that
game is so damn old right you you turn
on that game right now you find a match
no exaggeration two seconds automatic
hey no matter how long because because
like gears which is a much more recent
Jack has told me multiple times that you
try to look up and on rank you can't
find a match after time I've never
gotten last where I couldn't fun no
matter what time of the day like I could
go on 3 a.m. in the morning it's a match
no no yes they combined the gear servers
I got a good multiplayer yeah but I'm
saying like they can find the gear
servers with PC and Xbox and you still
can find games on there and you also how
come you can still play Killzone
Shadowfall
a large title faster that you can play
Gears or crackdown if you know I don't
know buddies please I think that's why
you never had a hard time fighting a
game on its that we gotta fly through
listen let's get into this a PS 5 you
know we gotta talk pricing strategy how
can they come through on the on the next
generation obviously you know I'm saying
like what are the things that can
you the most for ps5 in the next-gen so
let's get this lost Oh Scott you set
this one off you know what are the
things you're most looking forward to
that you want from PS 5 not talking
about PS 5 because it's irrelevant right
now after I'm worried about playing the
last of us part 2 goes to SEMA death
stranding one truth concrete genie and
the full game of drunk Rajini look
better than dreams with me he's not
buying a PlayStation 5 knock that out
the park's playstation 5 is irrelevant
why are we talking about we still got
great games coming out no released about
the clarify awesome so you are convinced
that those games goes to steam with the
DES trainings Last of Us they are
definitely coming this generation as
opposed to PlayStation 5 launch titles
so themselves right but why the world
would you not utilize a hundred million
user base absence absolutely some of my
question because we are talking about
PlayStation 5 or what do you think
they're gonna launch with what do you
think the strategy is they're gonna be
able to just basically read a quote
unquote backwards compatible remastered
version though same games ok that's
that's the best move the launch time is
for the ps4 gonna be alright let me let
me so first of all they are gonna beast
am i relying on backwards compatibility
of the of the major games that they
release at the end of the ps4 generation
goes of Tsushima Last of Us all of that
right they're gonna be staff depending
on that and then you do have guerilla
games whatever whether it be like you
know you know because those rumors have
them working on multiple things whether
it be a day a horizon sequel it could be
that or you know whatever their other
studios are working on those maybe also
launch titles or because this is very
plausible and you know let's be real it
could be nothing because Sony
only historically are either just
average too mediocre when it comes to
the games they release at launch they're
just not data they don't get they seem
to not care as much as they should
about launch they care about they care
about they start caring 40% through the
gen that's gonna be like okay listen
let's drop all the hot [ __ ] all right
now let's turn alright but what now I
mean actually does regionals got also in
reference to I forgot this point in
reference to price point for psy I think
this is finesses why am i what do you
think it comes through at psy we hearing
about the tech we ain't about the ray
tracing we're hearing about the SSD
sound and lick you know I'm saying all
these high power features do you think
they come again with the 400 they take
that take the loss on the hardware side
or just because of these robust features
they're talking about that they gotta be
500 which I think I think I think it's
dictated by the state of the economy
whenever it launches no more than
anything no kind of thing I think it's
hard to speculate at this point because
the economy could be way better so that
that point could be way more if it's if
the economy is starting to suck and you
know they'll have to come up would you
pick it up at 500 so Scott would you
stay broke I couldn't afford in the
background does not support you you'll
find all that stuff back there sorry
makes much of way sir coming through by
the way just for the record I want to
say I made that bet with smooth way
before any of the talk about SSDs and
all oh you know all this plastic know
that you have a finesse your way out of
a back because you lose this good I
always appreciate a you know an
opportunity to flex my fonescu
I bet I pretty much bet Smoove that uh
pretty much the bet was um that the PS 5
would be $400 if it wasn't that if it
wasn't then I would buy him an extra an
Xbox pretty much and if it was he would
buy me the next Playstation 5 BG huh you
can still win that just call it
inflation uh that could have been that
could have been a finesse but I I
settled with him I I offered him a
settlement and I said if I pretty much
said if you accept this offer right now
you know will pretty much personal
vesemir
will erase the original bet and he will
guarantee what the price is he'll get
what I said six games second games which
equals up to $300 so shout out the BG
lower floor finesse I think you should
just roll that all the way to the end
Lord
Kratos what are you thinking they're
like PS 5 how do you attack this thing
and what about that price point ring
well yeah and launch I believe because
they've kind of demo a few things I
believe Gran Turismo 7 is gonna be there
for lunch you right in the beginning
they already built the GPS for it based
on on you know all that stuff what other
games could come you know I don't know
the only one Kratos me would you believe
but I'm gonna set this big listen you
know as the king of racers won't give me
a Gran Turismo or give me um she give me
a launch MLB next you know you know grow
and in Indian think about it right we
still got V R so the VR that we have
we're gonna be able to work on a PS 5 so
give me some of those somewhere those
titles so to tell you the truth most
people because of this generation they
were already sold on the PS 5 so it
didn't matter what price it comes at it
doesn't matter what they already sold
because they're looking for the sequels
to the games that they got Kratos man
may I
real quick yeah okay I just want to add
here's what sells ps5 I forgot to
mention this
Kratos vs Thor okay s man that that game
there's another three three to four
years a year or two after now so then we
can get the complete game supposed to
come over first of all the amount of
content that was in that game the amount
of content that's in God war blow blew
even my mind nobody expected you know
bro they told us it was only good we
heard from we heard from Corey that it
was gonna be like 2025 hours it was
exactly that no was it no no the game
was not know 2025 hours it's only twenty
twenty-five hours if you literally only
did what you absolutely needed to a game
right way Logan is I did everything and
I did all that stupid stuff on my
playstation game a great place Xbox 360
level one hey David we need to make sure
that you didn't put it on
Kratos because you know this shady stuff
people out here sending people they save
files myself actually I gave it bigger
but I thought Spider Man was a better
game because it was a completely but let
me say this let me say this real quick
right okay so people are saying like
some people write it's incomplete
because you could see some other realms
that you can't get to but here's the
thing right they never meant for you to
go to every single round because if you
can get to every single realm there's a
whole bunch of things that you could
access that you shouldn't be able to
access yet so what are they gonna do are
they gonna okay are we gonna not put
these realms there even though people
obviously know they exist
alright and just pretend that they
shouldn't be there and then in the next
game suddenly
oh here's the realm that you that you
couldn't get to when you're using the
little will thing like they had to be on
the will like all right had to be there
all right BG what purchased your car
right your car got five gears and you
can only get to three gears or you that
car back are you gonna be satisfied with
your video that this is like saying this
is like saying any game that has an
expansion or a sequel not as incomplete
it is not this like the same thing I
want to buy as guard now who told you
that that supposed to be in the first
game well the game showed me spider-man
showed you the other boroughs
[Laughter]
here's the here's the thing about God
award yes
so as you're using your your reference
to hell out of you already using the
reference of the first three gears out
of five right well the first three gears
are the best so fourth gear and fifth
gear suck anyway so who cares but what I
will say is here's my problem with God
award you get to the stranger fight and
that was by far one of the most epic
battles I've ever experienced in a game
ah and here's the problem when I played
all the other god awards the very first
ball ah spot you're like damn this is
the first boss fight I can't wait til
the last one because they always got
better yeah God war that was the best
part of the whole game that's what you
never yeah
I disagree was my that was my large part
I feel you know because I felt the same
way I felt that you know fighting the
ogre the same over the same animation
same thing over again
I understand what were we going with
that because I thought also that that
first epic battle set me up for a fall
you know yeah
BG counter and then we gotta get a Queen
Valkyrie was the best boss fight in the
game now she made me wait to die I did
go back like three or four days back
before I choose out of control yeah she
made me angry I didn't like her give me
God award just for the Flex no there's a
safe there's a safe file yeah that's my
prized possession in that game that say
father says I be they don't give me got
a war sorry no way dude you couldn't pay
me enough money to do that that sounds
like a nightmare about that later but
for halo Lord addict man what do you
me from PS 5 what do you need from me
what about that price point it's a
blood-borne - mmm ok ok overrated trash
it doesn't matter
best games he's been roasting faint news
that's not the best game I'm curious
what this man plays no no that is the
last time and I was the lord of the Last
of Us right there
toy boy at that price point what you
think they come in it I think they're
gonna come in at four oh okay
Lord sovereign price point and then also
what do you need from PS 5 sent to
general it's gotta be five man it's
gotta be there's no way that thing is
any less than five then the L they take
that hundred dollar l is too much
they're not doing that not for the NASA
they talking about so it's a 500 dollar
machine and me I mean I'd like to see
again all of those cross streams like I
said before all of those goes to
Tsushima that's training all that to me
I'm seeing those this PS 5 games for me
unless they come out with a good
difference between the end of the
PlayStation force like when the launch
of that that I could wait um then I
can't wait that I'll play them on paper
but not otherwise I'm playing those on
PS 5 oh I like to see infamous - I mean
yeah I wasn't being good it was
beautiful kool-aid character when they
got rid of him I just felt felt yeah it
was pretty but it wasn't nearly as good
as wanting to know I definitely infamous
again no doubt Lord King what you need
from PS 5 okay um what was the price
point that the PlayStation 4 came in a
I had to go to a majority on there 400
hours um I believe they couldn't keep
that trend I believe that they felt that
$500 $600 thing that they did with the
PlayStation 3 was a death sentence um I
think they're going into this they
understand where they have to be and
being that they won't have any next-gen
titles to launch with like I don't
believe in the Gran Turismo 5 stuff
launch and I don't believe that whatever
he told me whatever talk about racing
and no disrespect cradles I'm going to
give you a racing game what was that
other racing game that they cut down we
didn't use the license and make jobclub
2 and get that game out there I don't
gran turismo usually comes in the middle
of the cycle you know maximize those
dollars I'm so I do believe it to be 400
I don't think that they can play in that
space with Microsoft going into this
next generation and as far as what
Solomon said yeah definitely I'm not
mine now one of those titles on that
PlayStation 4 that their PlayStation 4
is gonna be used shout out the silver
for arm to go for my PlayStation 5 so
full at least five six months I'm
getting maximum dollar on that
PlayStation 4 so it's going right to the
store right the game stop because that's
where I'm gonna get my playstation 5
trade your for edit yeah very good
how is it cuz a lot of people think this
or they've said this before some kind of
way they think that the xbox was
justified in its multiple $500 prices on
its systems but and then then they said
the the zone they feel like the
PlayStation should always be cheaper
than the Xbox and I don't get that
or that theory I guess that's because
your company's not succeed at $500 just
don't keep your gun from a truck mindset
sir no no these have money Oh spending
$500 for Xbox anytime but they
a problem with spending $500 to make
jewelry I think at a point on Kratos I
think that I think what it is is because
a lot of what let's be real like what
started a degeneration to the to
deathblows right we know about the use
games it's how you trade use games right
that's what Adele blow and then other
one what's the price point you know say
we got we got to keep it true as far as
some definitive factors in the beginning
that gave them the jump shot you know
and the fact that they were actually
more powerfully we're doing a 1080p most
of the games so um I think people are
just assuming that they would do that
but I agree like a lot of people pay had
no problem paying $5 for next right you
know why that what he's saying is true
it was a period tech like when the tech
is superior people is gonna pay superior
Tecmo
right so is it an instruction that the
playstation 5 is gonna come in a little
bit under or what anaconda is so we
expect that anaconda to be price-wise a
little bit more than we expect the
playstation to come in a little bit less
we want it to come in a little bit less
I hope it comes in a little bit less I
hope it comes in at their $400 you
understand because so it can justify
that price because if the anaconda is a
little bit more powerful and they come
in at the same price point they can't do
that like you can't I don't care what
games you got on debt you can't say $500
and you can't have you can't match them
horsepower for horsepower or what about
what about the exclusive line of King I
miss you know I'm beggars they got even
those banging you know all people going
by so I mean in in Sony's defense
Microsoft doesn't have that software
cachet they can get away with that like
dig these guys got a lot of like you
said the spider amazing they get sitting
on so many sequels the hurrah you're
looking at pedigree and nurses and issue
launch titles right now those to launch
that and I think like sovereign said
they're gonna leverage those ended a
year on end of their cycle games and
then PlayStation four years ago such a
summa on their stranding all those games
yeah be able to play them at higher
resolutions better frame rate on a
PlayStation 5 they got me for that I'm
gonna get that I don't want to buy those
games if they're inferior games on the
PlayStation pro I don't you
not get that decision sir oh yeah off
stage with the cells which I think he
wants in the region
Oh vacation five or five hundred dollars
and $10 increase on Pearson the
paymaster that is so excited do you
carry the two thousand which at yacht
big lost soul aside a ps5 title or ps4
what was the loss other side okay okay I
don't even know about that one that's
what sir let me jump in home cuz you can
you make some good points look I think
to me they if they come with five
hundred I'm not gonna be upset you know
I'm saying obviously we heard all things
they talking about the rate race in st
all that strong stuff and the CPU and
stuff like that but um to me like I
talked we talked about what's the to our
peers ago I want to see where they come
in PS five price point and that Lockhart
price point I'm I didn't know what that
is but I will say this if Sony's
aggressive and put out that 400 mm-hmm
that could dictate a lot to stack a set
it off like if they four hundred you
know weeks we got last of us to you know
I'm saying whether it's gonna be a
cross-generational title or launch you
know we'll see okay
go sis is Seema we talked about I look
crazy you know I'm saying I personally
don't like VR but at the end of the day
they have stayed committed to it we know
they're gonna double down on it if they
got the untether joint you know I'm
saying gonna be a more powerful version
they sitting on stuff so you know we'll
see you know see and we'll see what's
going on with that the last point was
the anyone get out X we will come home
is um obviously we know no III right but
aside from that what is the most
disappointing thing that can happen for
solely for the remainder of 2019 so I'm
gonna get BG I should ever get the Lord
set it off first let's get the Lord
added cuz I know you got a role sue
adequate what's going on man what what
what it upsets you VR a little bit of VR
and a lot of VR in the bushes you're
worried about no no
about it all right no doubt no doubt
Louis saw what would piss you off for
the remainder that's what he might be
with slowly
I think if none of this happens right
what if whatever would be said is right
and there's more last of all there's
nothing like that and there's nothing
the rest of the year like it's nothing
like the kind of pissed off because I'm
looking forward to the last you know
piss you off this would be the most
disappointing for the PlayStation fanboy
in my chest right cuz he didn't there he
and they each scream he locked up in
there if they come out on Microsoft
stage would be kumbaya the PlayStation
dude is like yes bring them onstage with
a kumbaya it will be disappointed and we
elating all the decision Larry's Lord BG
well is the most disappointing thing the
story can do to end this generation in
2019 all right Bee Gees in the bushes
hopefully we get them back Lord silver
what is the mo house on mute my bed I um
I just like I would like Last of Us to
come out this year I don't think it is
but I would like it and I just think
that man I don't cuz I'm not really
expecting I'm not expecting that that
that much I understand this transition
period yeah I just you know I'm just
overall kind of bored with the fact like
I said that they haven't been you know
in the multiplayer spear that this
generation I think this has like been a
terrible generation both of their games
good point good point so you will be
saying like these no multi play and yeah
just in general like I feel like I
haven't really had no you know
multiplayer games to play no doubt Lord
silver what would piss you off the way
okay two parts to the same thing a would
be
if the collectors edition for the
license part 2 is $250 that would suck
and then I think if the well this this
is this is since I made myself quit
playing online this would be a good
thing but also a terrible thing is if
the last was multiplayer is battle
royale only only that means I'm happy
because I don't have to worry about
playing I also want to play it so if
it's battle royale only I refuse to play
it so that's that's probably I'm gonna
go with each other than that Sony drops
greatness year after year every year
yeah worried about don't be disappointed
right right wait so are you good good
people good oh one more thing
y'all refrain from throwing around
anaconda so much because every single
white guy it's very uh it makes me feel
very young emasculated fair enough Lord
Kratos this is what I'm curious about
what would piss you off oh it
disappoints you for the remainder 2019
so would it make me I mean really pissed
off is if if all we get from here on out
remain at a year if we don't get any
more of those big triple AAA game yeah
you know I love the V arm and it really
tied to me over it really gives me
another way to play the smaller titles
like medieval and stuff like that you
know you know although that is good and
dandy you know and I buy it all and I
play and I enjoy it all but to just have
days gone as one of your big this year
would to me that'll be disappointing and
only because my expectation is that
they're gonna release at least they have
to release one of their big four other
games that they have this come on just
give us one and then read next next year
you can do whatever you got to do
something you feel you create Kratos you
you know you didn't took the shop in
very lenient right they're not they
didn't have a PSX like I've been nice
like okay what they're doing this for
reason but that reason better be
validated by something and not just
because you was trying to save a few
bucks fearing it would piss me off I
feel you I'm with you got Curtis got any
of my notes right now yeah I just need
one banger one last bang close it out
whether it be and I'm saying like I said
The Last of Us
you know I'm saying or yeah you know say
cuz two guys better be prepared to be
pissed off Liz that's al for me I'd like
let's just finish strong yeah you up you
cut the piece going joint you know I'm
saying and I got a attic you're gonna be
mad but uh I want dumb if it's gonna be
for next gen this what id place T's we
gotta bring back to ogia this you know
six we gotta bring this black credo is
trash you have a pen they had to have a
patent for a new world a new hand you
know they asked well I'm super oh boy
it's a remote play you got it got party
chat yep between between boys budget
they had trophies back Tony I'm gonna be
a phony pen for new handheld as a Sony
pen for new L oh but maybe the way to
keep the price down from there right is
just make the system where it's again
it's a remote play make it that is only
cloud and able with mikrosil nothing the
system just maybe that's what all this
stuff this pile stuff
maybe they bring the Vita back and
20:19 prediction series through him as
well let's start off with Lord BG where
can the fire people find you and what do
you have going on sir I am struggling to
pay play days gone and in the time that
we in the no joke then you can check my
Twitter and the time that we've been
playing out this from been doing this
podcast I ran into like three seriously
ridiculous ridiculous bugs and I
uploaded them to Twitter
so I'm literally going I'm literally
driving like maybe 5 miles per hour on
the bike and I'm driving into camp and
then oh one of the NPC spawns like in
some into my bike and then my bike gets
thrown across like Ross and then I
instantly die these girls live Israel
after driving like five miles an hour
and then a bear like Christ will attack
my bike and then the bike launches the
bear like 20 feet into the air like in
the OBG salute for coming through below
with the pleasure you already know Lord
kratos back in the realm talked in that
song but growing on by the way could if
I people find you what you got you guys
can find me on Twitter at Jacobs cities
16 trying to keep you guys left gifts in
the means you know what I mean just
starting a youtube channel man just
start a new one you guys I was gonna
struggle with it I mean but this one
here you know build it out right and got
some big things coming so say we link up
your Reno and of course the man who has
been super late
did they represent only flag hard mom
male or Silver's I was going on but
wicked father who finds what you got
going on I only really do to Twitter
dude is YouTube if you watch the weenie
podcast I explained how I went to my
daughter's soccer car at the time I was
coaching at soccer or football depending
on where you're from and one of the moms
came up and she's like hey I came across
to gaming channel and it was in that
moment that I realized I need to stop
doing YouTube this is embarrassing it's
all get up so I don't really mess
youtube a whole lot anymore that yet go
on Twitter and I basically you'll find
me trolling my children every
day it's what I do [ __ ] yo twit you're
tweeting from it
I got appreciated absolutely brother
pleasure one of the best game families
in the vram and that last of us talk is
always legendary so we gotta get you
back you already know when yes sir thank
you luli already known in Lords in the
realm Lord addict I know you gotta roll
out soon we can if I've been friends
what you got going on there you can find
me getting off the podcast cuz I gotta
go I get to work don't go fight and fury
no Lord sovereign battling the evil
silver from your Twitter loss of io p bx
xbox live like i said last week what is
holidays for the mic today i know i did
you don't so yeah i like i said last
week we planning some stuff for e3 so
look out for that in terms of stuff on
the show florence from the stuff they're
gonna be doing from the complex i know
king is some things percolating so look
out for all that stuff no doubt your
lord you can't even be a me when I Lord
king out here taking these one people to
bend me all type of subjugation going on
out here this was your moment to talk
your talk so the wicked if I've refined
you and the king of statue what is going
on sir hurts of foremost I would like to
thank DG I would like to Jack thing
j-dub and I would like to thank silver
um BG had I was I had the pleasure to be
on weapon will and treated me fantastic
the show was fantastic
sick um and he's a he is a friend to the
realm acts here a true gentleman thank
you so much for showing up sir I do
appreciate it and I love all the
commentary that we had gone with each
other in the dialogue was great um
anything with Jay dubs j-dub is my dude
will be out and I'll lay together we
will be at fan fest and I can give him
the Grand Tour how Microsoft really do
think so I really think you're gonna see
a different j-dub after III seriously I
think he's gonna change a lot of bed
might do everything was the first time
I'm meeting you and it was fantastic I
love the dialogue I love the premium
stuff in the background
I love the repping 100% it was a great
show and I do appreciate you coming
through it was fantastic thank you so
much I would never know finds that you
don't do to Twitter but Twitter's late
man make sure you all that's gonna be in
description when it go up yo saluted
each everybody was lit fantastic we're
you know we got one more left y'all
ready know who that is
you know so that would be prediction
series next week we'll release the guest
run later in the week so get a little
surprise low tension going up but yeah
shalu to the panel everybody man j-dub
self obg Kratos all that man it was
fantastic chat was lit and you already
know the audios won't be able to tonight
more cardbox we will have that shout out
to the stream team or PD
l-boogie the crew old-school style MJ
the boss I saw you in there you go.you
up in there your boss moose esta vez
chop to screw your Easter
yo shad once again me that net we got
some great articles up right now talking
on that cloud so extreme and so you boys
out there please support the realm on
that everybody enjoy your Sunday if
anybody got anything else we out of here
please